Uh,
the,
the great political philosopher Thomas Hobbs,
um,
who if you haven't read,
you will be learning something about in the section reading this week,
uh,
Thomas Hobbes formulated his theory of the state and his ideas on political
obligation in the context of the civil wars,
which tore apart all three of the constituent kingdoms of Britain in the 1640s.
Um,
and when it was all over,
Hobbs who had returned from exile in 1650s wrote a history of the conflict,
uh,
which he called behemoth published in 1662.
The titles up here and he began it with this wonderful sentence,
the first sentence of behemoth.
If in time,
as in place there were degrees of high and low,
I verily believe that the highest of times would be that which passed between
1640 and 1660.
And what hubs meant by that striking sentence was that the events of those two
decades unleashed consequences of an enormously far reaching nature in politics,
of course in religion and also in the realm of ideas.
Things would never be quite the same again.
But if that's how it looked to Hobbs at the end of the whole process in the
beginning in 1637,
none of that could really be foreseen.
In 1637,
Charles,
the first experiment in personal rule was going well and he had just succeeded
in winning legal backing or be it narrowly for the continued collection of ship
money.
Uh,
an annual non parliamentary tax.
But Charles has relative success dependent upon two things.
First of all,
he needed to avoid unnecessary expense,
especially the kind of expenditure necessitated by war.
Part of the reason for success in 1630s was that he had kept the kingdom at
peace.
Secondly,
he needed to avoid calling a parliament.
He needed to avoid a parliament,
which would be a forum for deeply alienated elements of the political nation who
loathed his fiscal expedience on the one hand.
And on the other hand,
his Armenian policy in the church,
he needed time for such opposition to die down,
if it would.
And in 1638 to 40,
all of this collapsed.
As I mentioned at the end of the last lecture in 1637 Charles and Archbishop
William Lord overreached themselves by attempting to impose uniformity on
religion throughout not only England,
but also Charles has other kingdom of Scotland.
They attempted to impose episcopacy and an Anglican style prayer book upon the
Church of Scotland in 1638 the Scots led by many of the leading the ability and
backed by the general assembly of the Church of Scotland,
formed in Edinburgh,
a national covenant taken by all the leaders of the movement and many others to
resist innovations in religion,
and they proceeded to raise an army.
In 1639 Charles proved incapable of finding the resources to put an effective
army in the field to stop the Scottish rebellion,
and the Covenant has effectively overran the whole of southern Scotland.
It was completely in their control in desperate need of funds.
The king was forced to call a parliament,
and in 1640 the Ritz went out for what came to be known as the short parliament.
The elections which were held in that year were unusually fraught customarily in
most counties or urban constituencies.
Election contests were relatively rare.
Usually people somehow by consensus managed to decide who would represent them
in parliament.
In the elections for the short parliament,
research has shown that in fact there were contests in no fewer than a quarter
of the constituencies,
a very high number for this period contest between candidates who were regarded
by the electorate as on the one hand courtiers and candidates who were regarded
as having country values.
That is to say staunch traditional Protestants,
adherence to the rule of law,
supporters for parliaments continued place in the political process.
When the short parliament met late in April,
1640 it immediately took up the old tactic from the 1620s of agreeing that they
would vote the king money,
but only if their grievances were first remedied.
And indeed,
the very first speech made in the short parliament in the House of Commons
declared that the Scottish rebels were less of a threat to the kingdom than the
threat which was posed by the king's government to the liberties of the subject.
Charles responded by dissolving parliament after roughly three weeks,
hence its name,
the short parliament.
Charles then attempted to prepare to invade Scotland with the very inadequate
resources at his disposal.
Troops were raised.
They proceeded north and it's great disorders.
They would have low quality and poorly trained
and they were rapidly defeated by a preemptive strike on the part of the Scots
who crossed the border,
drove back the royal troops and occupied the whole of the north east of England,
including the crucial strategic center of Newcastle Center of the coal trade,
which supplied the fuel on which London dependent.
So the whole of the northeast of England was under Scottish occupation.
They then settled down waiting for negotiations and taxing the counties which
they'd occupied in order to maintain their occupation.
I should just mention the sudden success of the Scots should have been
predictable.
Many Scots had served as mercenaries in the armies,
particularly of Sweden and of the Netherlands in the 30 years war.
They were very good experience soldiers.
They'd come home to defend the covenant.
They were led by David Leslie and general with a great deal of experience who
distinguished himself in Swedish service.
England had nothing comparable militarily,
well humiliated and desperate.
Charles called and other parliament.
This one to meet in November,
1640 and the whole country was galvanized by this second election.
There were even more election contests.
It's thought that about a third of constituencies were contested in the
elections for the long parliament.
Indeed,
it's been suggested that nationwide,
perhaps between a quarter and a third of all adult males voted in the election
for the long parliament.
The members elected arrived in Westminster bringing with them petitions from
their counties,
cataloging their grievances against Charles has government.
There was a tremendous unity of purpose amongst them.
They knew that this time the king could not afford to dissolve parliament if it
opposed him.
When parliament met,
the initiative was immediately seized by John Pym,
who rapidly emerged as leader in the House of Commons.
He was a veteran of the battles in parliament in the 1620s and knew exactly what
he was doing in an early speech.
He alleged the existence of a plot to introduce popery and arbitrary government
emanating from some of the king's counselors.
Early in in the meeting of parliament in its first session in November,
1640 this allegation developed into direct attacks upon the king's needing
counselors,
archbishop laud and Thomas Wentworth heard of Strafford.
Both of them were imprisoned on the orders of parliament and Strafford found
himself the object of impeachment proceedings.
Then in December,
1640 parliament received graciously from the city of London,
a petition known as the root and branch petition against the episcopacy of the
church and calling for further reformation in the church.
It was accompanied by large demonstrations of London citizens,
orderly demonstrations accompanying the petition to the parliament,
but it showed how well London was organized in opposition.
Okay.
In February,
1641 after a brief recess,
the triennial act was passed and the king was reluctantly forced to agree to it.
The Triennial Act laid down that in future parliaments must be elected every
three years
and a few months later.
In May,
1641 the king further agreed that the present parliament could not be dissolved
without it's own consent.
The spring of 1641 also saw Strafford impeachment proceedings in the House of
Lords,
which gradually turned into a trial of the entire regime of the 1630s in
particular,
the exercise by the king of forms of arbitrary power with Strafford backing.
According to the allegations,
and in May,
1641 Strafford was the object of an act of attainder.
The king was reluctantly forced to sign his death warrant and he was executed.
Then in the summer of 1641 came a batch of reforming statutes,
the prerogative courts,
which had enforced the royal will in the 1630 especially the court of Star
Chamber,
which had dealt with dissidents what abolished ship money was declared illegal.
The other financial experience which had been used by Charles and the 16th
thirties we're also declared illegal and to all of this,
the king reluctantly gave his ascent
by the high summer of 1641 then it looked as if parliament had one.
Charles's innovations had been reversed.
Strafford.
His strong man was dead.
Lord was in the Tower of London.
Parliament had secured for itself a regular place in government.
Through the triennial act.
It appeared to have been a bloodless or almost bloodless constitutional
revolution.
Okay.
But of course the game was not yet over.
Parliament went into recess in the summer of 1641 and Charles took the
opportunity to travel to Scotland.
There he agreed a settlement regarding the Church of Scotland by withdrawing his
earlier demands and this secured the withdrawal of the Scottish army from the
north of England
in early November,
1641 when parliament met again.
A second major event occurred.
News arrived in London of rebellion in Ireland,
a Catholic and nationalist rebellion involving allegedly massacres of English
and Scottish settlers in Northern Ireland.
Now,
I should take a moment to explain briefly the Irish situation.
In the aftermath of the rebellion against Elizabeth by the Earl of Tyrone.
In the late 59 nineties
land had been confiscated from the chief tons of northeastern Ireland,
the area known as Ulster and that land had been planted with Protestants
settlements,
mostly peopled by,
by settlers who came across from Scotland,
such southern Scotland and from England.
Their relations with the Irish population were fraught from the beginning
by 1641 some of the Irish chieftains in Ulster resentful of their loss of land
and have power in that area.
Planned to imitate the Scots by rebelling,
seizing control of the Irish government and then negotiating a better settlement
once the rebellion began,
however,
they proved unable to control it.
Some of their followers began killings of settlers and seizures of their land.
Meanwhile,
the so called old English aristocracy of other parts of Ireland,
most of whom were Roman Catholics.
They were descended from medieval Norman conquerors of Irish land known as the
old English.
They joined in the rebellion,
principally motivated by the fact that as Roman Catholics,
they were fearful of a puritan dominated parliament in London and what it might
mean for them.
With the joining together of these two sources of discontent in Ireland,
the rebellion became both a religious,
a Roman Catholic and a nationalist rebellion fueled by bitter resentments
against the plantations in the north marked by massacres and evictions of
settlements.
It's estimated the fingers keep changing as more research is done,
but perhaps 4,000 Protestant settlers were killed and some thousands more
probably died of cold and hunger during the winter of 1641 to two
so island had exploded and news of these events sometimes wildly exaggerated bad
enough as it was what confirmed,
it seemed to members of parliament the fears that there was indeed a Polish plot
afoot,
but it also raised the crucial question of what was to be done in the face of
this new rebellion.
Could the king be granted an army to suppress it?
Could he be trusted with an army?
Would he not use it first against parliament?
On November the 23rd 1641 John Pym decided to press ahead.
He introduced into the House of Commons,
the so called grand remonstrance.
It was a long document,
a comprehensive indictment of Charles's misrule.
Ever since he had come to the throne in 1625 all of these points set out in
order to justify the demand that henceforward parliament should have the power
to choose the king's counselors,
thereby having control over whatever forces might be granted to the king and
that an assembly of divines should meet to determine the future structure of the
Church of England to satisfy the puritans zealots amongst pim supporters.
This radical action finally split what had been hither to a fairly unified
opposition to Charles.
This seemed to confirm the theory that there were indeed popular spirits seeking
to undermine the monarchy and the ancient constitution.
So both of those conspiracy theories,
which I mentioned last time seem to have been confirmed by events.
There were also some members of parliament who much as they opposed Lourdes
innovations in the church did not want a puritan assault upon the episcopal
structure of the Church of England.
That was going too far in their view.
The whole issue raised by the ground remonstrance the many issues raised by it.
We're passionately debated in a session which went on until two o'clock in the
morning when it was finally passed by the House of Commons by only 159 votes to
148 and narrow victory for John Pym.
He had the grand remonstrance printed and distributed outside parliament into
the country to win support.
So with the grand remonstrance,
what had been a virtually United opposition to the king was dividing.
And it was the fact that that once United opposition split that made possible
civil war,
it made possible the kings rallying of a party to his course.
On the 23rd of December,
he rejected the grand remonstrance and then on the 4th of January,
1642 he attempted a coup by coming in person to parliament with troops to
attempt to arrest the leaders of the House of Commons.
The five leaders that he was looking for escaped had been forewarned of his
arrival.
They fled down river and took refuge in the city of London.
Faced with this situation,
Charles withdrew from his capital.
Some members of parliament were also withdrawing quietly,
leaving parliament and going back to their estates.
Queen Henrietta Maria left and went to France to consult with her brother Louis
the 13th and to raise money as possible to buy arms for a royal army.
In June,
1642 oh sorry.
In March,
1642 parliament passed an ordinance known as the militia ordinance.
An ordinance was not an act of parliament.
A full active parliament needed the king's signature.
They had decided to pass ordinances with the force of law to legislate without
the king and they pass the militia ordinance seizing the right to raise troops
and appoint military commanders.
So they too were preparing to raise forces.
In June,
1642 they offered to the king the so called 19 propositions.
This included such terms as or privy counselors should in future be approved by
parliament or major officers of s of state should be approved by parliament.
The militia order allowing parliament to raise troops and upon commanders should
be accepted.
The king should consent to whatever reform in the Church of England.
Parliament advised
Charles replied to this ultimatum that if he was to accept this,
I'm quoting him,
it would be the total subversion of the fundamental laws and excellent
constitution of this kingdom for he continued parliament never was intended for
any share in government or the choosing of them that governed
okay.
Now,
of course the king was technically right,
but things had passed beyond the question of what was or what was not.
The excellent ancient constitution to which both sides continually appealed in
different ways.
Both sides of the dispute had now subverted the ancient constitution,
which they professed to revere and under the pressure of events,
they had gradually entered completely unchartered waters,
a situation which no had envisaged,
let alone planned.
Okay.
In July,
1642 parliament voted to raise an army.
In August,
1642 Charles having rejected parliaments terms raised his banner in the city of
Nottingham and called on all true subjects to come to his support.
In fact,
by the time Charles raised the royal standard at Nottingham fighting had already
broken out in the town of Manchester in the northwest,
where the townspeople resisted the attempts by one of the king's supporters to
see as the town's magazine of arms.
The first shots were fired that day.
England was at war,
at war with its own king and at war with itself.
So
by the time civil war broke out in July,
August,
1642 the combination of a determined effort to reverse Charles the first
policies in church and state and the unforeseen circumstances provoked by the
Irish rebellion had led parliament to make what might reasonably reasonably be
called revolutionary political claims.
But how far would it go and where would it end?
Those questions were now to be settled by war,
and it was a war which itself unleashed a further dynamic of unforeseen
circumstances,
unforeseen consequences.
That continuing dynamic,
perhaps derived ultimately from the complexity of the causes of the war and the
various machines of motives which led people to fight.
And also from the remarkable dread breadth of voluntary participation in the
war.
The participation in the fighting was remarkably wide.
Socially,
it's been estimated that perhaps a fifth of all adult men in the kingdom fought
in the civil war.
Now,
historians have long argued the toss about the real causes of the war.
It's one of the great debates of English historiography,
and usually when they do so,
they try to emphasize a particular dominant variable in their own
interpretation.
They frequently seek for a single prime mover,
the dominant cause.
Really,
I think that that's a foolish exercise because the essential point,
it seems to me about the civil wars,
is that they were about subtly different things to different people who
participated,
and indeed all of the competing modern interpretations be they wig or Marxist or
revisionist.
All of them can be prefigured in the views of some contemporaries themselves.
Different people at the time thought the war was about different things to the
Scots.
It was about religion and the t distinctive institutions of what was still an
independent kingdom.
Even if it had the same king as the Kingdom of England to the Irish,
it was about land and about religion amongst the English.
Some royalist join the king simply out of loyalty.
He was the king,
some sort of themselves as defending the monarchs,
legitimate constitutional rights against popular spirits.
Some saw themselves as defending the Church of England against a puritan plot to
dismantle it.
Some Roman Catholics joined the king.
Many of them joined the king.
In fact,
out of fear of what a puritan victory might mean and in the hope that if they
supported the king,
he might grant them future toleration in the exercise of their religion.
Some gentlemen joined him because they feared social disorder.
They feared that a collapse of regular government would lead to a breakdown of
social order,
a fear which was much played upon by royalist propaganda,
which stressed the plebeian nature of many of those who had shown support for
the parliament.
The demonstrators in London,
for example,
parliamentarians were early labeled by royalist propagandists as roundheads
people with short haircuts,
which meant common people not wearing the flowing locks have a gentleman
on the other side.
Some parliamentarians saw themselves as defending the ancient constitution and
the law against the king who could not be trusted
if they had encroached on the powers of Charles.
The first,
it was not because they were attacking monarchy as such,
the battle cry for the parliamentary area and armies was for the king and
parliament.
Whereas the war cry of the rightest was simply for the king.
But the parliamentarian slogan was King and parliament.
Others saw themselves as defending English Protestantism against Polish
innovation.
Many banners of regimens raised in the parliaments support had religious symbols
upon them,
some soil as the Ma,
the moment at last at which they could move beyond the traditional Anglican
settlement and achieve a full of reformation in church and nation.
Much intensive research has been done on side taking and it suggests that both
socially and geographically were differences in the composition of the two
sides.
But really they would just differences of degree.
They were not absolutely clear divisions.
So for example,
two thirds of the House of Lords were for the king,
but one third of the Lords fought for parliament,
the earls of Manchester,
of Bedford.
Of Warrick of Northumberland and others fought for parliament.
Most of the gentry actually managed to stay out of it altogether,
but of the very large minority who did fight,
no significant difference can be found in terms of their relative social and
economic position where the differences can be discerned.
They seem to have been differences of principle,
sometimes religious principle,
sometimes constitutional principle.
So this was a war in which many of those who took part understood it as having a
powerful ideological element of one kind or another.
And much of this was true also of the common people because they didn't
participate simply as dutiful tenants or pressed men.
Of course,
some did,
but many voluntarily took part
predictably.
The loyalties of the so called middle sort of people counted most the kinds of
people who are leaders in their townships and parishes and they seem to have
been moved by similar motivations to those of the gentry.
Amongst them.
We hear most in contemporary sources about a tendency to support parliament.
Most of them seem indeed to have been on that side.
We mustn't forget that these were people who also participated in local
government,
or be it at a humble level.
Many of them,
if they had free hold land or citizens of towns with a broad franchise had taken
part in the elections.
They were people who had signed the county and municipal petitions,
which had been brought to the long parliament in 1640
and amongst such people amongst the middle sought as contemporaries called them.
Uh,
one Contemporary Observer,
Richard Baxter tells us there were many good Commonwealth's men as he described
them,
concerned about law,
about taxation,
about the liberties and survival of parliament.
Though Baxter added that amongst them also were many who were sensible of these
things.
I'm cutting him sensible of these things,
but much more sensible of the interests of religion.
Again,
ideological issues percolating far down in society
as with the gentry.
Most of the middle sort of people did stay out of it,
but if those who voluntarily participated,
a great many were for the parliament,
a mirror image of the aristocracy and the major towns and industrial areas where
all parliamentarian in sympathy.
So one could say if the royalists propaganda of the early years of the war
tended to be aristocratic in tone,
a good deal of the propaganda of parliament was aimed broadly in society and was
somewhat populist in its tone.
So for many of the middle sought to this was there,
cause also,
but be that as it may,
they didn't call the tune.
Both sides of the war were directed by gentlemen and in approaching the actual
events of the war,
it helps to consider what their war aims were.
The aims of the king and his advisors were simple.
The king intended to win and then dictate terms to a defeated parliament.
To that to end his basic strategy was to consolidate his control of territory in
the north and west of England where his supporters were in the majority and then
to advance upon London and take the city.
Early in the war,
his principal base was established on Oxford in Oxford.
I'm from Oxford.
He intended to advance to take London simple enough.
He almost achieved it in 1642 when some of his troops arrived on the very
outskirts of London and were turned back by armed apprentices from the city were
advanced to meet them.
I turn them green.
The Reuters,
for whatever reason,
chose not to attack.
They retreated and the city was saved.
Turn them.
Green incidentally is on the tube line as you go in from Heathrow airport to
central London.
If you ever going in that way on a visit to London,
you'll go right through them.
Green,
not all who fought for the king high of a shared these simple war aims.
There were plenty amongst them who had actually opposed him in 1640 but who
couldn't bring themselves to fight against him.
They would have preferred a negotiated settlement,
but although Charles occasionally paused to engage in negotiations for tactical
reasons,
it's unlikely that he ever did it.
Seriously.
The war aims of parliament were different.
Parliament neither sought nor expected,
an outright military victory.
The aim was to achieve as strategic superiority,
which would then force the king to come to terms.
The idea was to hold the south and the east at the major cities where
parliamentarian support was strongest to contest the north and the West in order
to weaken the king and above all to prevent the king from taking London.
Parliamentary armies were organized in regional associations based on
associations of counties who raised troops to operate only within their own
zone.
In addition to which a field army was raised under the command of the Earl of
Essex,
which had the principle duty of protecting London by shadowing royal forces in
the Midlands.
So the war consistent for the most part of a great deal of regional skirmishing
in the provinces and local campaigning by one garrison against another all over
the north and the West and the Midlands and then campaigns in which the major
field army shadowed one another mostly in the South Midlands and in the
approaches to London with occasional pitched battles when London was seriously
threatened.
Yeah,
such was the basic situation in the first two years of the war from 1642 to 1644
but as the war continued,
the experience of a conflict of the conflict and the need to respond to the
situations that had created began to release greater passions and to create new
war aims
militarily and politically.
The pattern was off summer military campaigns followed by winter politics when
the armies were simply and camped in winter quarters and the result of the
summer campaign affected the politics.
The result of the winter politics affected the next summer campaign.
That's how it went.
In the summer of 1643 the king came very close to winning again.
He consolidated his strength in the north and the west and seemed poised for a
victorious strike.
Politically parliament saw the emergence that winter of three broad groupings.
There was a peace group in parliament who thought it would be best to negotiate
with the king now and get the best terms that could be obtained before
everything was lost.
On the other hand,
there was a so called war group.
They had become convinced that only and more aggressive military policy would
succeed in bringing the king to terms and they'd have to defeat them militarily
first before he would talk seriously.
And between the two was a large middle group,
which could be swayed either way by debates in parliament.
Late in 1643 the war group with the backing of John Pym,
who at this time was actually dying of cancer and had died by the end of the
year.
The Wall Group decided that it was necessary to try to bring the Scots back in
in order to break the royalists hold on the north of England.
And in September they negotiated the solemn League and covenant with the
Scottish covenanters.
It was agreed that the Scots would aid parliament militarily,
but the price of their support was acceptance of reform of the Church of England
according to the word of God and the example of the best reformed churches.
That was the wording and to treaty.
The Scots understood that to mean Presbyterianism and assembly was set up at
Westminster of English divine's more than a hundred ministers,
a number of lay commissioners and Scottish observers to discuss a future
religious settlement.
Almost simultaneously in the autumn of 1643 Charles agreed a cessation of
hostilities in Ireland,
the Irish rebel confederation held power there.
The cessation of hostilities by the remaining royalist garrisons was achieved in
order to get aid for the king from the Irish rebel confederation.
They would bring in reinforcements from the West.
All of this,
both the bringing in of the Scots and the bringing in of the Irish rebels of
course inevitably heightened the already existing sense of the war as being in
part a religious conflict.
1644 brought another shift.
The entry of the Scots facilitated parliaments recovery in the north.
The Scott swept south again recovered Newcastle and began besieging the city of
York.
Charles detached his nephew,
Prince Rupert to relieve the threat to York,
which was an army which proceeded north and expected an easy victory in
relieving the city.
But he got quite a surprise.
The Scots together with the army of the Eastern Association,
which was based in Cambridge and had men from the eastern counties advanced
north to join the Scotts and fought outside of your outside York.
The great battle of master and more at which the royalists under Prince Rupert
were utterly defeated.
The parliamentarian victory was in particularly due to the role of the cavalry
of the Eastern Association under the command of a figure who was rapidly
emerging in the parliamentary forces.
Oliver Cromwell and brief word about Cromwell.
Cromwell was a squire of um,
high birth,
but low means a younger son who had been MP for,
um,
Cambridge in the long parliament and who had left parliament in order to raise
forces for the Eastern Association at the outbreak of war.
It gradually risen from captain of a troop to Colonel Colonel of a cavalry
regiment.
He was a man who has been described as a man of agonies and exhortations,
passionately religious,
something of a depressive.
He found himself in the war.
He found the cause he'd been looking for and his troops were known for their
training and their discipline.
It was,
they're conducted Moston more in particular their capacity after a charge to
rally reform and charge again,
which had done a good deal to defeat the gallant,
but much less disciplined royalist cavalry.
The total victory which was achieved by the Scots and the Eastern Association at
Moston more was a considerable shock,
the first complete parliamentarian victory,
but the momentum of that victory was squandered by the parliaments commanders in
the south,
the decisiveness and the incompetence of the senior commanders of the South,
the Earl of Essex,
and the Earl of Manchester meant that the year ended once again in stalemate.
There was another indecisive holding battle to stop the king reaching London at
Newberry while the Earl of Essex advanced down into the west of England,
God himself cornered and had to surrender and have his troops ignominiously
transported by c back to the southeast,
having surrendered their arms to royalist forces there.
The second battle of Newberry holding the king back again from reaching London,
brought to a head the growing tension over parliaments.
War aims,
Cranwell who'd and south with his cavalry to join that,
uh,
to join Manchester at Newberry pressed the Earl of Manchester to continue the
battle to try to turn it into the dis,
a decisive victory.
Manchester refused to do so.
It was enough for him to stop the king from advancing further towards London.
According to their recorded argument,
Manchester declared to chrome.
Well,
if we beat the King 90 and nine times,
yet he is king still.
And so we'll have his posterity be after him and we subjects still.
But if the king beat us once,
we will all be hanged and our posterity be made slaves.
In other words,
he didn't dare risk a decisive battle to which Crum well replied.
Why then if this be so,
why did we take up arms?
At first?
The recriminations continued bitterly in parliament during the winter,
resulting early in 1645 in a victory for the party in the House of Commons.
First of all,
they'd decided to dissolve the existing parliamentarian field army,
and to form what was described as a new model army,
which would be paid and controlled from Westminster and would incorporate the
best elements of all previously existing parliamentarian forces and be free to
operate wherever it was needed throughout the kingdom.
Secondly,
they passed a self-denying ordinance.
The self-denying ordinance required the resignation of all commanders who were
members of parliament.
It was a clever move to forced the resignation of the incompetent as democratic
leaders of the parliaments troops.
But there was one exemption from the self-denying ordinance.
Cranwell was exempted.
His native military genius by now had shown itself so clearly that he simply
couldn't be spared.
He was appointed left 10 in general of the Horse,
not commander of the entire army.
The Lord General was so Thomas Fairfax,
the leader of the parliaments cause in Yorkshire.
Cranwell was his left hand in general in command of the cavalry.
Meanwhile,
the war conditions,
we're having an anticipated painted consequences elsewhere.
London was a city in ferment.
1640 had seen the collapse of censorship of the press and a proliferation of
pamphlets arguing different political and religious ideas.
Something in the region of an average of a thousand a year were being printed in
London in the early 1640s the first newspapers were beginning to appear
reporting on the events of the war 10 a week by 1644 they had also been a
collapse of church discipline.
Radical religious groups were emerging from underground and meeting openly.
New groups were forming in the debate over future religious settlement.
The city was highly politicized and a wash with all kinds of heterodox ideas.
In 1646 a Presbyterian Minister Thomas Edwards was so shocked by the ideas that
were circulating in London that he wrote his work gang greener,
which was a three volume catalog of the heterodox opinions circulating in the
city.
Edwards was an Orthodox Calvinist,
utterly horrified at what had broken forth and he was not alone.
Many more conservatively minded members of parliament in matters of religion
began to favor a Scottish style Presbyterian settlement,
which would at least restore order and orthodoxy in matters of religion.
And a group of parliamentarian,
Presbyterians were able to push through acceptance of a directory of worship,
which would replace the Anglican prayer book and to vote in favor of a
Presbyterian church structure to be imposed when the war was over.
Others.
However,
including all of the chrome,
well,
we're not alarmed by what seemed to be a new age of the spirit in matters of
religion.
They favored independency congregationalism in church government.
They were opposed to the imposition of any form of coercion in matters of
conscience.
So in these debates going on in London and in parliament,
religious liberty was emerging as an issue.
And for some people,
another aim of the conflict,
which had not been previously foreseen.
It was in 1644 the pamphlets advocating religious toleration.
Um,
we're quite widely printed and it saw the printing of John Milton's great area
of forget occur.
His wonderful statement in favor of freedom of speech and thought
equally worrying to the more conservative members of parliament was a situation
in the parliaments army
like the city.
The army was a concentration of tens of thousands of people in a mass situation.
A most unusual social situation.
The army was full of volunteers.
They were disproportionately men of puritan inclination in religion.
Many of them were for London or East Anglia or the godly are areas of the north
and the Midlands.
By 1644,
Oliver Cromwell was already well known to favor such godly men and to have a
preference for promoting them on merit,
a shocking idea to 17th century sensibilities.
Famously,
he declared in one argument over the promotion of a junior officer.
I had rather have a plain russet coated captain who loves what he fights for,
who knows what he fights for and loves what he knows.
Then what you call a gentleman who is nothing else
with the formation of the new model army.
In 1645,
all of these elements were brought together and it took on a very distinctive
character.
The new model,
especially amongst it's junior officers,
was full of Cromwells russet copilot captains who knew what they fought for and
loved what they knew promoted on merit.
It was a praying army,
uh,
preaching army and Godly army.
Uh,
surprisingly well,
disciplined army by the standards of the day.
And in 1645 that spirit both contributed to and it was enhanced by victory,
just 17th century sensibilities.
The proof of God's favor and with victory came quite exceptional morale.
In June,
1645 Fairfax and Cranwell brought to battle and decisively defeated Charles's
main battle army at nays be in the Central Midlands.
They then rapidly moved West Corner,
the army of the Wa,
the royalist army of the west at Lang Port in Somerset,
and roundly defeated them.
By late 1645 and early 1646 it had become largely a matter of the army bottling
up what remained of the king's forces in Oxford,
seizing and capturing the city of Bristol and then mopping up the last royalist
opposition
by net.
May,
1646 the king seeing that there was no possibility of military recovery left
Oxford in disguise,
traveled north and gave himself up to the Scots at Newark near Nottingham.
He thought he'd get better terms from them.
So against all initial expectations,
parliament had won an outright victory.
Achieving that victory,
however,
had released forces which could not easily be contained or pushed back into the
bottle.
After one of the last skirmishes of 1646 the royalist commander,
Sir Alan,
absolutely surrendered his sword to his parliamentarian opponent,
then sat down on a drum and is said to have said to the parliamentarian
officer's,
well,
boys,
you have done your work.
Now you may go and play unless perhaps he will fall out amongst yourselves.
And that was a very prescient remark because the business of establishing the
terms of settlement with the victory achieved gradually turned in the next year
into a struggle over what was the meaning of the parliaments cause.
And we turn to that next time.